[Musique]
depuis quelques semaines les jardins
familiaux de montigny le bretonneux
peuvent de nouveau accueillir leurs
locataires
il avait été fermé dès le début du
confinement au départ seuls les
propriétaires de poules avait obtenu une
dérogation pour venir nourrir leurs
animaux grâce à une autorisation de la
préfecture il est désormais possible de
jardiner depuis la mi avril
une centaine de membres est concerné
chaque jardiner en fait à sa spécificité
on peut dire et donc chacun voulait être
plutôt favorisé enfin ne pensait qu'à
son cas personnel pratiquement donc il
fallait concilier tous ces petits cas
personnel et trouver un compromis en
s'accordant avec les directives
préfectorales
donc on a abouti à deux heures les
propriétaires de gallinacés peuvent
continuer à venir entre 9h et 10h pour
les jardiniers le créneau est compris
entre 17 heures et 19 heures avec
toutefois des règles précises la chance
que l'on là à montigny c'est que les
jardins sont tous numérotés
il a été décidé que les jardiniers qui
avait une parcelle numéros pairs jardine
ray les jours pairs et les numéros
impairs les jours impairs de ce fait que
les jardiniers par cultivant n'étant pas
côte à côte
la municipalité a également mis en place
des contrôles de police afin de veiller
au bon respect de ce nouveau règlement